lewis and his colleagues since 1978
have been publishing articles exposing
the various
operations of the cia all over the world
and some of the threats to civil
liberties and democracy
that this organization has contained
lewis welcome to alternative use
thank you i'm glad to be here first of
all how did you get into the cia
watch business and what led you and your
colleagues to found
the covert action information bulletin
well i've been uh a journalist since the
1960s and actually 1966 i spent nine
years in southeast asia
and it was really there that i first
came to grips with what the cia
does in the world that its main function
as i learned at that time in laos in the
philippines is
intervening covertly in the affairs of
other countries and in fact
covert action by the cia's own
definition is
activity secret activity which can be
carried out without the
knowledge of the targets of that
activity
being able to learn that it was carried
out by the cia or
in fact by the us government and what
led you
and your colleagues to found the covert
action information bulletin
when did you begin to do this well it
was
uh after a long succession of efforts
largely growing out of the watergate
revelations
of the church committee and pike
committee reports even the rockefeller
commission reports which documented
gross and ongoing and very large scale
cia covert activities that had been
carried out up till that time the
american people
didn't know very much about this and
that was
really what the cia is about is keeping
it secret from the american people
in in in some the cia's activities of
course are known to the people who
against whom they're carried out but
it's the american people who are the
last to know about it
and we as a result of a lot of those
revelations
and a lot of other people who were
concerned about it decided to try and
put together
a journalistic effort to look into these
areas there was a
another magazine counter spy which
started
earlier and after several years it
it bit the dust and we decided after two
years in 1978
to start covert action information
bulletin well it looks like there's
going to be
some real problems coming up not only
just for you and
covert action information bulletin but
also for civil liberties in general in
the united states and finding out what's
happening what our government is doing
in our name covertly around the world
with the intelligence identities
protection act
just about to be passed in congress and
with reagan's executive order 12
33 things are going to be quite
different shortly aren't they
there is clearly a a very
marked escalation towards secrecy in
this government
uh these two pieces of uh one
legislation and one executive order the
executive order does not have to be
propounded by congress congress doesn't
have a single word to say about it
basically these two working in tandem
with each other
along with other efforts by this
administration
to embed the cia
and the other intelligence agencies of
which there are some 18
federal agencies in secrecy
this bill is the cia's greatest
operation without any qualifications
it's
better than in terms of their interest
than when they install the shah in power
it's uh better than the coup in
guatemala
and of course there are many failures
from their own point of view better than
putting pinochet in power in terms of ci
values
what it is is nothing less than an
official secrets act
this is the the legislation that the cia
has been trying for 30 years to get to
give it
legal protection and legal exemption
from freedom of speech and freedom of
the press
now what makes it such a beautiful
operation is that it is in the process
of being passed it's going through the
congress more or less like a dose of the
salts
with the senate voted on it a couple of
months ago
the vote was something like 90 to 2 and
the house it's expected to pass by a
similar majority
and yet the american people by and large
including media people including
television
interviewers across the nation and
journalists are oblivious
that it's even passing much less what it
really means
now what it really means see it's
couched and what makes it such a typical
and beautiful ci
operation is that it's couched in the
terms
of protecting our agents who are out in
the cold risking their lives to defend
the country
this is senator benson was the original
sponsor of this bill by the way
and this was what he said about it in
many speeches here in texas now it's
passed to uh
senator john chafee and jake garn
sponsoring the bill
in washington now who can argue with
that legal protection from our agents
whose names are being exposed by
irresponsible people who don't agree
with the government's policies
now if the facts were that simple if
those were the true facts
who could argue with it but the truth is
that these agents
lives are not in danger because of their
names being exposed the truth is that
these agents are functioning from
embassies with diplomatic passports
under circumstances
in which if the worst possibly happens
and they're absolutely caught
buying secrets from some local spy agent
a minister in the government or what not
the worst that will be
will happen to them even in the soviet
union
is that they will be asked to leave the
country under no circumstances will they
ever be attacked or jailed or executed
or what not
by the government another government by
the host government where they're living
and breaking all the local laws by being
a secret agent and and recruiting spies
and inducing people to commit treason
now in in the four or five posts that i
served in overseas full time
we had full liaison with the president
of the country
the chief of the police and all the
police officers and all the military
officers this means that we met with
them weekly
in the name of the ci no secrets to have
lunch or dinner
and exchange information and do favors
for each other
if there were ever a terrorist attack or
threat against one of us the first thing
we would do would be to pick up the
telephone and call the local police
chief and say hey
there's a threat against us and i might
note that this would this would also
apply in the soviet union
if there were terrorist threat in moscow
against the u.s embassy or a u.s case
officer ci man they would call the local
police and say you know somebody's about
to blow us up
there is a brotherhood of secret
quote secret police agents that
functions
like a brotherhood even when they're
supposedly on the other side they're
competing but it's sort of like
professional football players they're on
different different teams
but they're still professional football
players well you had buddies who were
kgb
played tennis with them played chess
with them socialized with them went
drinking with them and that was the sop
for all case officers
everywhere two thousand plus
well over two thousand names have been
revealed printed published
in the last few years and not one
agent has been killed because of his
name
being revealed now there were two cases
where it looked like they were put up
jobs
one and one which the congressman and
the cia always mentioned this
the research richard welch in athens
uh the 18th of december in 1975
was killed he was shot up by terrorists
in front of his home
and at that moment the church committee
which was in full session
was out of business washington every
door in washington closed on the church
committee because
as though the church investigation had
anything whatsoever to do with it they
flew him back and gave him a full
state ceremony which of course was
admission that he was cia to the world
i mean the headlines were ci chief kill
they didn't say
uh the third secretary of embassy killed
the united states government made as
much politics as they could out of the
fact that this man was a career
diplomat agent now the fact was they
caught the terrorists that killed him
and they they ascertained they verified
that those were the individuals who had
published his name
in an athens newspaper three days before
they killed him because they wanted
world attention to what they were doing
and it had nothing to do with the
investigations or publications in
washington and they already planned to
kill him
now this man had been ordered by ci
security to change
houses because he was living in the same
house
that eight other ci station chiefs had
lived in before him
generation after generation after
generation after generation of ci
station chiefs
had lived in that same mansion it was a
big villa and a very posh part of
athens as governments had changed coups
the colonel's coups
the monarchy in and out of power much
earlier and
dealing with all of the terrorist
activities and anti-terrorist activities
and coups in the middle east from athens
with the ci heavily involved with each
government and change of government and
the ins and outs
in these governments and yet the cia
station chief was living in the same
house throughout
eventually he was killed he refused to
move because he said it was a good house
now there is no way that that can be
blamed on u s journalists publishing
names in washington
moreover as i pointed out the cia the
cia director bill colby
exploited that man's death to make a big
issue and to effectively close down the
church committee
that was investigating the cia which was
investigating the practices the ci's
extensive malpractices
they put the church committee on the
defensive and out of business now
there was one other incident in el
salvador where two agents
who were under a labor cover
were killed by right wing by the
government uh police the secret plea
they're treasury agents is it in
in el salvador that do the the killing
down there now these
uh these two guys were in contact with
the government they were killed by
government agents set up in a hotel in
shot and the united states announced to
the world that they were secret agents
their names had been published much
previously but the united states
identified them thereby admitting they
were agents
and admitting that they were using this
labor organization as cover
where did they make this announcement
they did it the the prosecuting attorney
the state
the state department's representative in
the passport case in which they took
philadel's passport away from him
revealed the identities of these agents
and claimed that that
proved that people publishing the names
led to their deaths they were already
dead when the government chose
to use a totally fictitious a totally
false ploy to discredit philadelphia he
had not revealed their names
and so it's now in the supreme court
records
it's cited by the supreme court justices
in their decision against phil agee and
his passport
him keeping his passport these agents
being killed i.e the supreme court and
the state department reveal their
identities to accomplish their objective
against philadelphia
there was another situation in jamaica
where it looked like it was a planned
put up
in that case indeed the chief of
station's
house was shot up with machine gun
bullets and so they made a
considerable propaganda publicity uh out
of that with photographs of the bullets
but what it's true his name had been
published
but what happened is uh the back wall
of his garage well away from the house
received five machine gun bullets
at a time when his family was out of the
country and he was not in the house
and yet they tried to use that to make
publicity to show that it made it
dangerous to have the names revealed it
was also during an election
where the opposition to the social
democratic government
wanted to make it appear that terrorism
was rampant
in jamaica and so wasn't there some
political exploitation
oh indeed there was considerable
political exploitation of it
and and all evidence points that it was
it was the the government seek
uh secret police that fired the bullets
right but but
again the the press in washington played
this as
played cooperated with the ci to give
publicity uh
for the for the bill against the
exposing of names
there's no real need for the bill it's
not protected in any way our national
security
that's not required by the history of
the cia
precisely on the one hand that's the
problem
and i i go a bit further to point out
that these agents 80
of them were identified from overt
information in the library of congress
the people publishing the covert action
information bulletin
go to the library of congress and go
through the state department's overt
records of its personnel
and come up with the ci officers names
infallibly because there are little
indicators in there which
you or you or you anyone can go in and
read through and say that ci and that's
ci and that ci
plus isn't just generally known in most
cia stations who is cia they don't
understand themselves to be known we
used to call it that uh contacts and
information we used to call it wearing
an invisible badge
you you acted as though you had a badge
ci up here you you
you drew people to you imci talked to me
you were taught to do this
allen dulles and the original ci great
in his book the craft of intelligence
makes this point that you have to be
known to be an effective
intelligence officer but see that's on
the one hand
the bill is is not necessary
and it's dishonest in that sense it's
based on false premises
on the other hand the bill is so written
that it goes far
beyond the protection of agents names
for example
the bill is so written that it will be a
felony for agents names to be published
even if they're already
to republish the names even if they've
already been published as in the library
of congress or anywhere else
it also includes activities of agents
so that you can if an agent
kicks in the door of your house and
rapes your wife or whatever
and you publish a story about it without
citing the name
it would still be a felony under the uh
executive
order so we have to see both the
executive order and the intelligence
identities bill
as almost part of a package
under the executive order the cia now
will be allowed and is allowed since it
was signed in december
by the president it is now law the cia
will be allowed to carry out covert
activities in the united states as well
as the all the other agencies too
so that if you were to discover for
example that a
member of an intelligence agency we had
infiltrated
say your church organization your
student organization
a trade union or whatever organization
or any group of more than two people
was infiltrated and you discovered this
and you so much as
mentioned it to a friend without even
writing a news article or without even
talking about it on the media
uh on television for example you could
be held criminally liable under this
bill and we're talking about a bill
which authorizes or which penalizes
persons and
for 15 years in prison i'm sorry five
years in prison
fifteen thousand dollar fine or both for
persons who've never worked in the
government
and that that's a pretty heavy price to
have to pay to
try and hold up your rights uh to stand
up for your rights against
the onslaught of the intelligence
agencies now the new york times
to give you uh the the proof of the the
the argument that this is an official
secrets act
the new york times in questioning the
sponsors of the bill on the floor of the
senate
pointed out that as it was written if
the london times
published a story about ci activities
and station chief
some scandal of some kind the new york
times couldn't
republish the london times story without
committing a felony
and the sponsor of the bill slapped his
hand on the table and said
that's right we want to knock off all
this criticism of the cia
so the situation this has already come
up with the revelation of cia activity
in iran recently which was not published
in the united states
for very long but eventually it got
either washington post or the new york
times did it
and there was a big uproar because they
were publishing it and
the in the last hearings the new york
times
uh questioning again senator chafee
about this bill said that
as they read it they would not be able
to
publish their very legitimate and
valuable stories
about the activities of cia agents ed
wilson
and frank turple who were selling
terrorist technology to libya after they
left the cia
without committing a felony and senator
chafee said
yes in the future the washington post
and the new york times will have to be
careful what they publish about the cia
i should say uh
if this bill had been law then we would
have never known about watergate
it was it wouldn't be to expose them
absolutely
but now it will be clear to many more
americans that there is a sort of a
split-level foreign policy as there is a
split-level
policy at home there is the rhetoric and
then there is the reality and
with secrecy in their best pocket they
can now
carry out a lot of these activities and
do it
as they say legally and what's once more
we're going back to the
the age of almost the cowboy politics
that the cia carried out in the 50s and
60s they claim
as a result of the church committee and
other revelations
that they don't do that anymore well
this administration is not only
not saying that but they're saying that
it's now legal and now
they're being very upfront about covert
activity in
many cases the covert activities are now
being overt activities
he's been talking about the cia being
the main
focus of this bill but it isn't just the
cia it's the fbi
where they're involved in quote
anti-terrorist activities and of course
reagan has said anybody who descends is
a terrorist and involved in
disinformation
that's no exaggeration that's great and
also any of the other government or
military
intelligence organizations i think many
americans
as a result of these two matters
and others also will begin to learn what
it's like to live in a third world
country which is being targeted by the
cia
many americans have lost sight of the
fact that many
citizens of other countries particularly
in the third world
have been the victims of massive cia
operations covert operations
everything from recruitment to bribery
to buying of an election on up the line
to
paramilitary activities and terrorism
training and torture
and even assassination and overthrowing
of governments
and i think that americans fail to
realize this until it starts sometimes
to hit them
at home and that's apparently what's
going to be
happening now and legally this
administration makes no bones that it
wishes to
that it sees its own people uh many of
us uh
as the enemy and in fact there are many
people i think in in the country who
consider themselves very middle of the
road who would be opposed to this
it it is absolutely incompatible with
our system of government as we have
known it in the past
moreover it's written to include
obviously more than the cia
that was the all government agencies
that have a right to secrecy
will be included in this thing john
isn't this literally unconstitutional
though
this is absolutely unconstitutional it
seems
to us that there are people in congress
who are prepared to
relegate the first amendment
to a lower priority and they are more
interested in what they call national
security
one member of congress as well as one
deputy director of of the cia
once stated that uh the first amendment
that's only an amendment
seems to me that's a rather shocking
description of
one of the hallmarks of of our
constitution this is why i call it their
greatest operation is they're doing it
without a constitutional amendment
which is beautiful in itself it is if
they propose to have all the states
ratify
a bill saying throw out freedom of
speech and freedom of the press and give
the ci
it would never pass but on the one hand
they're doing it without constitutional
amendments
and two they're doing it without the
nation even being aware of it which says
something about the vigilance
of americans and and their own feelings
about their freedom of speech
and press they could care less they
would rather watch a football game
why is this the case or why have they
gotten so far with it
without media scrutiny without public
uproar
etc it's not just the apathy of the
people listen it also
the media just hasn't reported on what's
involved in this
well the media in this country is is and
is the most apathetic that i've ever
seen in the world in terms of
playing uh ball with the administration
eighty percent of our news is reporting
quotations
of political leaders president reagan
giving a speech
in which everything he says is either
distortions
of historical fact or our propaganda
statements in effect
or both face lies all mixed together and
yet the press
will report his speech
as a fact it is a fact he made a speech
he said those words but they
they don't say at the end and everybody
in the room that it was all boulder dash
now there's a little bit more of that
with reagan than there was with other
presidents because he makes these
misstatements so constantly
he gets the facts screwed up so much but
the press
doesn't have any sense of defending its
own rights we have had an occasional
editorial
including in the austin american
statesman saying that the names of
agents bill is unfortunate
and that's about the size the new york
times ran an editorial saying
this is unfortunate they said it was
kind of it was kind of wistful i read it
when i was on my way to lecture at
yale and wesleyan a couple of months ago
and i read it in the new york
times they were saying golly gee whiz
they mean this thing to apply to us
too yeah there was another in which they
mentioned lewis wolfe
and they said well it's a bad bill but
on the other hand we've got to take care
of people like lewis wolf and maybe
john stockwell they cannot believe
that the this that such a thing will
actually
apply to them but uh unfortunately the
cia has many allies in congress and some
even in the media
and so sometimes you can pick up a
newspaper
and read some of the cia's own
propaganda
coming from from some of those people
what is the source of the cia's power in
washington
well i think it's the whole
idea that the cia has built up
even in the halls of congress that it is
somehow a sacred entity
and that while there was a lot of
criticism
of j edgar hoover of the fbi uh
not a whole lot of it while he was alive
it's all happened since he died
um it's interesting because
it is known for example that hoover had
a lot of information and a lot of very
damaging information against members of
congress
it is also clear that the cia maintains
relations with a number of congress
people
who have some of whom have said so on
the floor of congress that
they are in close contact with the cia
and uh
this bill for example which was written
by the cia and they said so deputy
director frank carlucci said it on
national television back in 1978
and said we are now about to deliver
this bill up to to congress
that's a little bit of a strange way for
laws to be written
if they're going to be written by the
cia now what this bill is it's part
of a number of bills and legal
precedents that the government
is obtaining to keep now they're not
going to go out and arrest the editor of
the new york times and put him in jail
for 10 years
the week after this bill is passed
they're not that stupid
but they're getting they may arrest lou
wolf if he violates it i think they
probably would because they could make
propaganda out of such an arrest but
what they're they're doing is they're
getting that bill
they're getting the passport ruling for
example
they're getting the other legal
precedent such as the lawsuit against
frank snep marketing myself
and travel restrictions they're getting
authority for the secretary of state to
throw people out of the country who
should have political exile here such as
the el salvadorian refugees and they're
getting these things ready so that the
next
war that they get us into as in vietnam
they will have the legal power muscle to
handle it differently
than they did during the vietnam war to
handle the centered home
to make it impossible to speak out the
descent that choked
off kissinger's and nixon's and before
that rusk's
efforts in vietnam the dis the popular
uprising at home
that forced the united states government
to abandon its
policies and plans in vietnam will not
be
nearly the government will have weapons
to crush
such a thing in the future it'll have an
official secrets act to make it illegal
to publish stories like milai and
whatnot because they were obviously
secret agents involved
so the publication of the mili stories
would be a felony
jane fonda and cora weiss's travels to
try to
make communication and establish some
basis for working out a peaceful
solution to the thing
they would snap their passports up in
the future and
and then the other restrictions on
travel
the other restrictions on government
agents so that
an officer has been in the service can't
stop
and say we were bombing villages and
bombing churches and schools
that would be a felony he would go to
jail it's a british official secrets act
with a different name
you know you were mentioning a while ago
it's not only just the cia but it's
others too we had a program recently
which you may remember
about the greensboro massacres in which
the clan and the nazis
in broad daylight and in front of of tv
cameras
shot down five labor organizers
and killed them in greensboro north
carolina
it came out by the investigations that
bureau of alcohol tobacco firearms
agents was working with the nazis indeed
he was the one who gave
them the names of the people to be shot
also
there was fbi and local police
complicity
with the clan members as a matter of
fact it's come out that the
fbi itself established over 40 chapters
of the clan
over the years in north carolina alone
these revelations would be a felony now
yeah
exactly this passes it would be a felony
to reveal such information to the
american public
or government of by and for the people
is
is soon to be a thing of the past in the
united states what this will do is to
put the cia the fbi and these other
government agencies outside of the realm
of public criticism and even discussion
or law yeah
outside of the law because they've
broken every law of
man and god in in the activities they
have
conducted the the experimentation on
american citizens for example with
chemicals
and disease the propaganda of the united
states breaking and entering
colonel white's famous words about where
else can a red-blooded boy
lie kill cheat steal rape and pillage in
the name of the all-highest
now they will be able to that was who
was this this was colonel
george m white one of the founders of
the cia who eventually directed the
mk ultra program and he was retiring
uh he and i overlapped by about four
years he he came out of retirement to
address my mid-career seminar
and telling about how we put the cia
together and we did this
and the other in his letters memoirs he
wrote and then allowed it to be
published
that statement where else could a
red-blooded american boy
lie kill cheat steal
rape and pillage with the blessings of
the old highest
and that was before they had an official
secrets act to protect
their activity john there's been very
few people in this country that have
actually
told us what the cia has been up to and
exposed some of their misdeeds etc you
of course
and a few other former agents have
written some books and given lectures
criticizing
agents activities this would be
impossible
in the future would it not be we will
never know
uh the truth and the details the blood
and gore
the extent of of responsibility and
culpability
for the ci's program in nicaragua right
now
unless someone like reagan or in his
administ a top
official chooses to stand up and
denounce what's happening because
top officials are exempt from these laws
but we will never know the truth about
for example the shah and the evacuation
of iran
and which was a debacle i was told
by a friend of mine who who who was
close to a third friend of mine
who was part of the ci security
establishment
and iran who said it was a debacle that
far exceeded the evacuation of vietnam
the the evacuation of the united states
from uh
from iran and uh this
this story will never come out and the
many other stories the assassinations
that probably are being planned today uh
such such as the coup in in uh el
in chile or the assassination of patrice
lumumba these sort of things are going
on
but the public won't know about them in
the future
why is the government been so outraged
by this publication
and putting so much heat on them i don't
think there's any other publication
in america that's had so much government
pressure put on them
then well you have two forces in the
government functioning here you have one
is an a defensive outrage against being
attacked
secret police organizations don't like
to be exposed and attacked that's the
same anger that they focused at me
people who are performing
activities that the the full
range of the society the 90 percent of
the society would describe
as depraved people who are doing this
while functioning under the cover of
being legitimate state department
diplomats prestigious
cover positions don't like to have their
activities and names published for what
they really
are this is traditional anywhere in the
world
the goon squads in chile don't like to
be attacked
nor does the kgb in in russia to be
attacked and exposed
but nowhere else in the world do they
become
as self-righteous and as vindictive as
they do in washington
where they they the united states
ambivalence
the duplicity the the the jekyll and
hyde aspect of the united states
character where we profess
such high ideals and yet traditionally
we have
ex exploited we we have engaged in
activities that
included uh dropping atom bombs on
women and children in japan eliminating
large elements of the indian population
of this country
and in the past 30 years killing
well over 800 000 people in the third
world
under circumstances that can only be
called terrorism
but doing it pretending all the while to
be
idealistic high-minded human rights
oriented
freedom-loving people now these
values are brought together in the cia
where people are diplomats
by cover and cia agents
by trade and when they have themselves
exposed
and have their children their family
their friends
find out that hey you weren't really a
nice diplomat all these years you were
in fact running the phoenix program in
vietnam that killed 40 000
people including many innocent people
this isn't this isn't something that
makes these people feel good and they
get very angry
moreover the nation in in the mid 70s
was clearly close to closing down the ci
to rejecting this kind of activity so
they were fighting
for their existence and there you get
into the other driving force of their
reaction against
lou wolf and bill shap and myself and
others
is just simply exploitation working
the the thing against uh the the people
who
uh there is a theory which is of course
nonsense that phil agee was
was sent by the ci to reveal names to
create an atmosphere which would lead
eventually to
an official secrets act now that is
certainly nonsense
and uh in the extent to which it
discredits
uh very honorable men you know i but
the fact is that they are exploiting
this revelation of names extensively
to affect the passage of an official
secrets act they were
they've tried every other way over the
past 30 years every other way you could
conceive of
they didn't succeed until modern times
and the curious vacillation of the
american public and washington and the
senators and
and uh congressmen in terms of just pure
conservativism and
callousness uh and i think that uh
american people really have to
understand that
it is their rights uh who
which are being threatened here now we
are
among many people ones who reject the
idea that it's
more important to protect our rights
than than people in other countries
clearly that is not the case the minute
we are involved in the torture or in the
death of a single person in another
country
our rights are being abridged in our tax
money to say the least is being used and
our humanity is being violated because
we're
being asked to accept inhuman acts
perpetuated in our name
as americans plus the fact that it
eventually will come home
if they use it successfully overseas
they'll use it on the united states
citizens as well
one of the most interesting aspects of
this
bill and the current environment in
washington
is to project what it does to the legal
system of a free society like ours in
terms of the individual
when you begin to give a a special
police a secret police a legal
priority legal freedoms and rights over
the citizens we have some examples we
don't have to speculate the bill isn't
passed yet and yet some of the things
that have been happening in the last few
years
illustrate what we can look forward to
for example
one to begin with a personal experience
i testified to the senate
a little over a year over a year ago
against this
bill i demanded the right to testify
because they had aclu testifying against
it and journalists
but no one who had been inside who knew
about
cover and could say this is [ __ ] i
was there we didn't do it that way
they they acquiesced and let me testify
now you have to write out a written
statement before you testify
and submit it and then you verbally
introduce yourself on the floor of the
senate i am so and so and what
and uh then proceed to make a verbal
statement which parallels the written
statement
the senate oversight intelligence
oversight committee
submitted my written statement to the
cia
for censorship the day before my
testimony
the cia struck out two parts
which were in the public record
published in my book and republished in
many magazines
overt information which both of you have
read and many other people in this
nation 40 000 people or so that bought
my book have read
which was not national security
information
but there were two things that i cited
that
showed the cia's disregard for agents
cover
it just illustrated the fact that there
was no that they weren't secret agents
the ci struck them out and returned the
report
deleting these points now
i was meeting with the representatives
of the senate committee
just before i went on to testify and
the senate uh legal counsel
the young attorney threatened me right
outside their office i didn't have a
badge to get inside their officer was
standing in a little foyer outside
and i mean finger in the chest
you know and i'm warning you john stock
well do not use the floor of the senate
to challenge ci
review like this and i'm backing up like
that
then we walk into the he didn't know
you're an international karate champion
and uh so then i went in to testify and
i began to introduce myself
and jake garns uh from utah
i was saying you know stock will 19
years the marine corps and marine corps
reserves 13 years in the cia
the wars and medals and whatnot to
establish the fact that i
you know i have certain credentials for
having served my country
and he interrupted me to say i know who
you are you're a traitor and everything
about you fills me with loathing and
disgust
and i said senator no one is going to
say something like that to me anywhere
and he said i just did i have my freedom
of speech too and grinned at the cameras
and i said yeah but the difference is
that i give you your freedom of speech
and you're trying to take mine away from
me
okay in frank snap's case where the
government
sued him to take a civil suit to take uh
take away the profits from his book
so-called they took away all the gross
res proceeds not just the prophets
they took him into the fourth oh yes he
couldn't deduct his
typing costs or whatever they took away
the gross of everything the book had
made
now in the first day of hearing in the
fourth district court under judge orrin
lewis
with all kinds of
attorneys and journalists attending this
thing
orrin lewis made statements which uh the
washington post three major newspapers
in the nation were virtually calling for
his impeachment the next day
for the bias of his statements he said
that it would not be necessary to have a
jury that he could handle it himself
he said that the facts in the case
didn't interest him one damn bit
he said that it was his objective to
take away from mr snap his quote
ill-gotten gains that was before the
trial even
this was the first day this was in the
first days of the thing
open mind he did this in front of like i
say 50 attorneys
who were there because of the the the
unconstitutional new law aspect of the
case
and journalists prominent journalists
from all over the world now
the the that's horrifying but what's
much more horrifying is what follows
frank snep and his attorney were relaxed
after that figuring that whatever
happened they had it won in the appeals
because of his incredibly prejudiced
statements
then and throughout the case he kept
interrupting
uh the the the state's council
uh to to disallow to protest
snep's positions and vice versa i mean
he was conducting
the the hearings now
snap and mark lynch the aclu attorney
working with him felt that they had
absolutely won in the appeals when they
got the court record
to go to the fourth district appeals
court in richmond virginia
those statements had been expunged from
the record
and the the appeals court refused to
address itself to the fact that orrin
lewis's prejudicial statements had been
uh written out the judge had gotten to
the court recorder and told him
to type the thing up without those
statements is that legal what
what's the status that's a pure raw
felony
or in lewis and the the the court
recorder whoever did it
uh should you know should get about 15
years for that but the courts refused to
consider the fact that the court record
had been modified there were 50
witnesses
three newspapers calling for the men's
uh in
virtually for the the man's impeachment
for his statements
and then when they get there the court
record has it doesn't say the same thing
that all of these witnesses said it did
afterwards
that's just one example this this also
shows very graphically how if you have
these police agencies like the cia or
the fbi
getting out of control how they corrupt
the entire legal system
and then the case of of phil agee that
we mentioned previously in his passport
hearing where the state
is revealing names falsely claiming
these men were killed
in order to prove a point to get broader
legislation for the cia and then just a
little case
that has no implications in terms of
names of agents bills or whatnot
freedom of speech but it illustrates the
point phil lichke
quit the cia he was writing a book about
koreagate which i hope he gets published
it's truly a horrifying account of its
own
about the inside story he submitted it
for review as the law requires him to do
they challenged it uh and deleted a lot
of things so then he would write
footnotes saying
the information blanked out in the above
paragraphs discusses a high-ranking ci
official
who was taken out by korean police and
gotten drunk
and coerced and without you know trying
to come up with a footnote and then
submit the footnotes for review
and he was truly a thorn in their side
and then they were having to address
themselves to
what of the footnotes could they because
you know they eventually have to defend
these things in court
but anyway he was working on his book
very seriously with them
through the review process his wife was
unstable treated for
mental problems in psychiatric treatment
she they were in the process of getting
a divorce
the ci had its councils work with her
and work with her counsels now they
claim this was necessary to prevent her
or the divorce proceedings from
revealing national security information
but she wasn't an employee of the cia
they had prominent ci i mean gs
17 cia officers go to the hear
the divorce hearings and testify against
philitsky character assassination saying
things that his friends would
absolutely deny in terms of his
character and his stability
and when he and his attorney tried to
cross-examine them
the court said no because of national
security they couldn't be
questioned on the statements they had
made about him and they were permitted
to walk out of the room without
cross-examination
so they could stand up and destroy his
character lying while they did so and
walk away without being cross-examined
now see the the the precedent in that
case means
that if the government begins to come
after people like they have to rewrite
the whole
legal system if they begin to prosecute
people under the names of agents bill
they can't you know the citizens defense
of this was the truth
this horrible thing was happening which
might make some points with the jury
cannot be brought out they claim
national security so they will allow
government
witnesses to come in and testify for the
prosecution
but they will not allow them to be
cross-examined to pull out the whole
truth to defend the individual this is
what we're getting into with the new law
legal libel legal libel legal slander
legal libel legal slander
legal biased information and depriving
the citizen the defendant of the right
to defend himself
to act to get the full information out
it's a new law it's a new era we're
getting into it's 180 degrees new from
what this country is all about
and again i repeat the irony that the
the beauty of it from the cia's point of
view is that the
great mass of the american people
including
the press and the movers of the society
are oblivious
of what's happening john we wanted to
thank you for coming on our show
to revealing to our audience here
exactly what's at stake
in this name of agents bill and we also
want to tell you that next week we have
some more revelations and startling
revelations about recent cia activity
with lewis wolff of the covert action
information bulletin who will be back
and john stockwell will again
comment on some of lewis's revelations
we'll have some more updated stories
about the cia so the cia watch continues
on alternative views
and now forsen john there has been over
the last few years
also a small handful of journalists who
have been sort of cia watchdogs
most prominent of which has been lewis
wolff we have an interview with him
maybe you can to introduce this
interview
tell us a little bit about louis wolff
and his journalistic
publications who is lewis and what has
he been doing over the years and why
is the government so outraged by him
well his background is is uh it's
thoroughly
uh legitimate standard if you will uh
journalism he was assigned for a couple
of years in manchester
writing for a couple of prominent news
organizations
manchester england yes manchester
england and uh eventually
made his way through london back to the
united states
where he gravitated
to a scrutiny of the cia and the
intelligence community
watching the revelations of the church
committee
information that he had come across in
his research some of which he had
published
as part of news stories previously other
parts of which he was not permitted to
publish by the nature of the
press establishment and so he uh
put together with bill schapp and ellen
ray the covert action information
bulletin
whose function was to focus on the
intelligence organizations of the united
states and discuss
and expose in a perfectly legitimate way
the covert action activities of the cia
principally as well as the other
intelligence organizations
i believe they formed that in about 1976
and have been in washington since
publishing
stories of true stories their quality
their
standards of journalism are exceedingly
high
that bulletin is distributed in the
state department and it's sold out the
first morning that it's put on the
stands in the state department news
stands
they also publish in that bulletin the
names of ci
agents and where they are now as they're
assigned and reassigned about the world
i believe that in very recent months
they have ceased the policy of
publishing
names because the controversy is so hot
and they would just assume and and also
it's never been their intention to break
the law
they've made that clear from the outset
bill shap
is the brother he is a highly competent
attorney
and is the brother of a top sportscaster
in new york city
he is a very articulate man himself and
has testified to the senate many times
against the names of agents bill for
example and and uh
defending what he and lou willford doing
and
uh after his testimony many times
senators
have come up and shaken his hand and
said i disagree with you but you
certainly make your
case for the legitimacy of what you're
doing very well
let's let's yeah let's take a look at uh
some of the things which lewis wolf had
to say
and we'll let you comment every so often
on greatest okay
what in the years that you've been
publishing it you think are some of your
most significant
revelations are there some stories that
even shocked you
well i think one of the big stories that
we were able to
document in some detail was the the
whole scope of cia activities similar to
what the cia did in chile and which was
documented by the senate select
committee
was the uh whole covert action
program in jamaica in between 1976 and
1980
and we were we did a great deal of
research into that
and we discovered many in many ways a
very similar program almost a classic
model that was followed along the lines
of of what they did in chile
including three major categories
military paramilitary activity
the use of propaganda in the in the
media
and the third one which was economic
warfare using
the multilateral organizations the
international
monetary fund and others to withhold
loans which had been promised to the
jamaican government
uh this is one example what are a couple
more of the details of that
you particularly mentioned those first
two examples of actual paramilitary
activity
well cia was involved in jamaica there
was a fire for example that took place
in jamaica of an old people's home
i think 150 old and infirmed women many
of them blind
were living in this home and as it
turned out
the place burned down in the space of
about eight minutes
seven or eight minutes it was discovered
that the phone wires had been cut
and that their exits had all been
blocked
even those who could see their way out
could not get out
and that the
means by which the fire was set was the
use of a petroleum jelly which was
unavailable in jamaica
this was one indication among others
that there was outside help
uh why would this why would the cia you
might ask why would the cia want to
murder 150 old women it was because it
was an effort
part of a very large-scale effort to
discredit the government in jamaica
which was at the time
headed by michael manley the prime
minister
there were images produced of michael
manley
in the media in the daily gleaner which
was the newspaper which the united
states
through the cia helped to support
and there is a good deal of evidence of
that there were images of michael manley
showing a death mask i mean it was his
face which had been
somehow made to look like a death mask
although it was
pretending to be a photograph of him
um and there were many ways to try and
discredit him this is very very similar
in fact to what the cia did
to try and discredit salvador allende in
chile
if you remember richard nixon instructed
the cia in a meeting which was in 1970
in the white house
and there was a document in the senate
report which is reprinted
and he said make the economy scream
those were his words
and that's of course what the cia
proceeded to do in chile and that's what
they also did in jamaica they also
furnished
a lot of munitions and assistance to the
terrorist
squads that were going around killing
people in the in the cities and also in
the countryside in jamaica as well
that's correct well john you had a trip
down to jamaica and you saw a lot of
these things about jamaica
with your own eyes right yes indeed i
uh a very moving a very interesting trip
to me
to see a target country
at a time in the height of a ci
operation when i was completely outside
so there's no way that i could see to
see the problem that journalists have
always had when the us government was
targeting on a country in a situation
trying to destabilize it overthrow or
manipulate the elections or whatever
of trying to figure out what's going on
when you don't
have access to all of the flow of cables
and
the discussions and national security
council meetings and whatnot
for the planning i observed that from
published information the cia station
there was quite
large for that size of a country it was
huge in fact it was
bigger than any station i knew of in
africa
although jamaica was a fairly small
island with 2 million people
that's typical of when the ci is got a
big operation going in a place they beef
up the station
and beef up the offices back stateside
the tone and flow of articles in
the gleaner what it was of course as lou
says
definitely a chapter out of chile or a
chapter out of the angular
operation every indication
of a massive ci operation going
to destabilize the government to make
the economy scream
and uh in that case i would say that
uh probably someone got promoted for
that one probably several people
because manly was run out of because it
worked by illegitimate
yeah without without a scandal without
an assassination without
the things that have caused the cia so
much grief
manly a champion of of social democracy
of of
giving the people a piece of the pie
was thrown out of office and an arch
capitalist
was put in office and and again there
was
minimal adverse publicity lou wolf and
the others were
studying the situation and did publish
about what was going on but it was not
published in the new york times in the
washington post and the big
the the big television networks didn't
do studies on it
primarily because even if the
journalists
of the big organs knew what was
happening and might have wanted to
they really just because of the secrecy
couldn't get the truth about what the
united states was doing
one interesting thing was that
the effectiveness of the lies the liars
in our governments you know the
duplicity when we formed the cia
we committed our leaders to having two
policies as loose as the rhetoric the
public statements
and the truth about what united states
policy is
so an interesting measure of of
presidents is how effectively they lie
interesting discussions that occur
inside the cia
is about lying would would you lie
you know you're the ddo and you're going
to testify to the senate in
serious discussions are you going to lie
because if you do it's perjury and
there's a chance you could go to jail
and yet you know the
organization expects you to lie
president carter was one of the most
effective liars
i have ever watched on television and
through the media
as a poker player men i would never go
up against that man
he could look at that camera and say
things
that obviously he knew were completely
and
totally false and i would study his
expression and i could detect
nothing except occasionally a little
wisp of a smile
that wasn't consistent with what he was
saying like he thought it was
funny but one of his more classic tech
actually
well the the the smile that i was
referring to wasn't that it was just a
kind of like he was repressing a grin
like he thought it was funny
how he rationalized these things i don't
know but one of his most
uh of conspicuous lies was when he sat
down with manly just a few weeks before
the elections
in washington and told him face to face
that the ci don't have the cia doing
anything to destabilize you or your
government we have no such program going
when obviously he did and uh
he pulled it off to the point where even
manly was troubled
very effective lie another major story
that we
we uncovered was the whole range of
cia media operations throughout the
world
we did an analysis of these operations
and the use of
money very large scale money is thought
between
one third and and forty percent of the
cia's budget and i should say that that
budget figure is the biggest secret that
there is in washington today
um at that time it was estimated that
the 1978 budget was
in the range of one and a half billion
dollars
a more recent estimate by a military
journal not the liberal journal by any
means
estimated that the cia's budget today is
in the range of 10 billion dollars
at any rate this analysis that we made
of the cia's media operations
disclosed among other things that they
deliver through
cia couriers ready to print
or ready to broadcast news
and i put that in inverted commas which
is
used by the media and this is
created by the cia how often
does the cia manipulate the media in
this way plant stories
get their views in the media is this
fairly common as a modus operandi for
the cia
it goes beyond your
in the course of the past 30 years it
goes beyond your
wildest imagination the extent to which
the ci
has gone to manipulate public opinion if
you include the mh chaos program which
was a billion dollar
program of setting up proprietary
companies setting up student
organizations so they could draw
radical students in and do every kind of
of duplicious manipulation
of of national student movements
press propaganda labor extensive
formation of labor unions
funding of major labor unions with the
objective essentially of manipulating
the mind and attitudes of workers
throughout the nation
and the world this was the essential
tool that they used to destabilize chile
and overthrow
allende was of course making the economy
scream
getting to the military officers but it
was essentially the truckers union that
finally brought the country down
uh and justified quote justified
pinochet j's takeover of power
5 000 university professors they've
co-opted this is church committee
revelations i'm not making this
up it's in print church committee's
revelations 5 000 university professors
co-opted to help the cia
manipulate people's minds 400
journalists in the us
including big-name journalists now
that's a big chunk
of the prominent journalist co-opted to
function routinely
to put help the ci put out the stories
and biases to the world
there are a whole range of of
areas wherein the cia provides briefings
to
selected journalists and there are
numerous cases where the cia has for
example
published books and several thousand
books were published in english
by by the cia and this is documented in
the church committee report
they set up 250 new services and wire
services
some of which not all but some of which
are still
in the pocket of the cia and i think
it's only fair to
to say that even some journalists who
don't realize
there are some who are winning but there
are also some who do not realize that
they're being
targeted by the cia when they come home
from a trip overseas they might talk to
somebody and they don't realize
at least right away who they're talking
to and then it turns out that they've
been the source of information which was
used by the cia
and then specific operations
around the world from corner to corner
to discredit
this individual create an impression
about that situation such as el salvador
the famous white papers in the angolan
operation
which i i note were you know back in
back in the good old days we did a
better job
our our white papers in the angolan
operation were based on very
specific photographs and heart
information of soviet ships putting into
portland and gula the white paper that
the cia produced for alexander haig to
justify the intervention in el salvador
was a piece of trash it was discredited
by the right and the left and the center
it didn't hold together i should point
for example to the
the stories that came out during the
angola operation where it was discovered
that
the cia was involved in a massive covert
operation which the
congress cut off when they learned about
it
there were certainly a small handful
really a tiny handful you could count
them on the fingers of one hand of the
members of congress who knew
about that operation and the scale of it
beforehand and then they cut it off well
one of the revelations at the time that
came out was that the cia had
created a story that was planted in the
media that the
cubans who were in angola at the time
were raping angolan women and that
they were really doing very very gross
things to these women
and killing them uh well it was
disclosed in fact by john stockwell
among other people who was the former
cia station chief
or in charge of the cia's task force in
angola that that whole story was created
by the cia station
in in zambia uh and in um
in zaire uh where they sat around the
table and
wrote this story and then it was fed to
a
a stringer who then fed it to a new
service who then got it to the ap
associated press who then picked it up
and was sent around the world and was
printed in
hundreds of newspapers as fact
but you can rest assured that
it it is at least very difficult for the
american people including us
to know what is true about the
sandinista government in nicaragua for
example
or about el salvador or about argentina
and the falklands right now our former
ally
of a month ago is now our enemy in this
confrontation
in jamaica for example and then this
this very
uh specific uh the the libyan hit
squad the not the mythical libyan hit
squad we had a situation where reagan
and president reagan and president
gaddafi
were confronting each other
internationally
reagan ordered our ship into what libya
claims as its
waters with the specific intention of of
either standing qaddafi down or
provoking an incident
and it worked he shot down two libyan
jet
fighter planes and then gaddafi was
incensed
and there was a credibility problem
there was the president of the giant
united states confronting this
relatively small arab country
i guess this leads us to your covert
action information bulletin
because there's a story in here about
the hit squads and it actually
originated apparently
with the israeli secret police the
mossad
it's a very interesting case study of
how
these propaganda operations can come
about
apparently since the israelis working as
they have
for many years very closely the the
israeli secret intelligence service or
mossad
uh has worked very very closely with the
cia and in fact
the cia helped to set it up back in the
in the mid 50s
originally part of the story came from
mossad that
there were two people who apparently
were
either employed or were agents contract
agents for mossad
who fed some of this information to the
us government
i see and the u.s government was fully
prepared to believe it
they said that one of their witnesses or
one of their sources
had been polygraphed and had checked out
his information it checked out
there was a story suggesting that it was
reported by one of the networks that
somebody had been offered a quarter of a
million dollars for his information
to the effect that there were hit squads
and some of it originated as i said from
mossad and some of it originated from
cia
fabrications jack anderson for example
reported that some of the information
that he had been given
and reported in his column had turned
out to have been cia fabrications
it's important to remember that the
israelis as much i guess as
the u.s considers it a priority to
discredit and to
possibly destabilize or overthrow the
libyan government and
one method that they saw thought of i
guess was to
create a story that said that libya had
sent death squads to
assassinate president reagan and other
high officials
go ahead well only recently uh some of
the same high officials who
before were saying that there were that
they had
evidence that some of these hit squads
had entered the country through canada
are now on record and quoted in newsweek
and other media
saying that they never located a single
person and a single single evidence that
there was
a hit squad and yet they say there is
still a threat
well um
i think it's fair to assume though there
is not enough information yet to say but
it's fair to assume that the cia was
hoping
through this to create a justification
for further intervention in libya
possible
military activity or economic boycott as
or blockade as they've now proposed as
has been proposed by the white house
well let's take a look at some of the
articles in the latest issue of the
covert action information bulletin not
only will it give you an idea of what
the
magazine is about it's sir oh my
goodness over 50 pages
but also it gives just this one issue
gives a good example of the widespread
operations not only of the cia it's not
to just restrict the cia but mercenary
activities around the world
as well
we have been following the sachel island
attempted coup for ever since it started
and we did a program with john stockwell
just recently where we
mentioned that i noticed um page four
you have an article that says shell beat
back the
mercenaries this is quite a complex
operation which
involves south africa and mercenaries
and the french
was the cia involved in that uh
there's still a lot of information that
will come out but
it is known that the some of the
activity
i i should say primarily the main um
source of the coup or attempted coup was
south africa
uh that south african intelligence
including one admitted former so-called
former
member of the south african intelligence
corps
who says that he quote unquote retired
in order to go for a visit to the
seychelles
for his vacation um
and largely the the the program was uh
initiated by the
by the south africans uh it does appear
however that the united states which has
had an ongoing interest in creating a
base of operations in the indian ocean
and the seychelles is is a very
strategic area not just because of its
it has no large natural resources as
such but that
it is a critical importance to to the
u.s as a jumping point
in in in the indian ocean it looks like
there are other aspects too that they're
also trying to
keep the government of mauritius from
becoming a more progressive
government there were some significant
elections coming up plus there was
something i didn't know at all and that
was the fact that there
is an island chained commodores which
actually
were taken over in a coup which were
carried out by mercenaries
yes uh that in that case it was largely
french intelligence which
was the source of that one there is some
indication that the cia
was uh involved though somewhat
peripherally in that one
so i can see where that could stimulate
people like in the
the group down in new orleans of
missionary of missionaries boy
they are in a way aren't they
mercenaries that
we're going to take over dominica
yes uh since the apparently the plot
fell
through for grenada and they've seen
that it can't happen in comoros that
they actually can take over an island
government and run it
the the case of the attempted coup in
dominica is a very interesting one and
here the u.s
involvement is rather rather
strong there was an attempt to build a
force
mainly made up of members of the ku klux
klan
clan
together with some other former and
active mercenaries
who had long involvement in u.s special
forces and
army background and
they at first their first idea was to
invade grenada
uh but then they realized that the
grenadine government
probably would be able to to uh offset
their activities and and probably defeat
them and uh
since their security forces are quite
well
organized there and so they changed
their
plan and and decided to go into dominica
the former prime minister patrick john
who was very very closely identified
with south africa
in fact he had helped to set up a
monitoring
station and also a base for
the manufacture of long-range
torpedoes which could be built with the
help of south africa on
in which he helped to set up uh
and basically uh
they had hoped he had hoped that if they
if the coup succeeded and he agreed with
the klan people
that uh if it succeeded that he would
give them
rights to casinos to gambling operations
to he would even give them several posts
in his cabinet if he came back to power
uh well of course needless to say it
failed but see was there some dopes
um some narcotics business exactly also
this is there often is in these things
this is on page 44 by the way we're
getting a little bit ahead of this this
is also
covered in the same in the same yes
this highlights a point though that
we've made several times on this show
how the cia will use
anyone to carry through their objectives
the ku klux klan
mercenaries the mafia drug operations
it's reasons like this that john
stockwell thinks that the cia
is completely corrupt an immoral
operation not to mention the 800 000
people have been killed through cia
operations
i think 800 000 is a very very
conservative figure but yes that's
that's uh correct uh there is clearly a
trend today
in the cia to to move more in the
direction of contracting out some of the
operations that it does not really want
to
get itself not that it doesn't want to
get involved but doesn't want to get
caught with his pants down doing it and
so some of the more
sensitive activities they're branching
out and letting other either other
intelligence services or other
quote-unquote private freelance types it
looks like
that they are developing a very
significant alliance with the south
africans
and the argentinas once again these are
both covered in this
edition of the covert action information
bulletin
angola the pretoria's continuing war
talks about the south african
involvement there mozambique rebels
exposed once again
we find south africa involved in that
and the cia in that case
yeah and the cia and then we get to an
article here about argentina activates
international death squads
and this article shows that these god
wretched horrible people in involved in
a tremendous amount of torture and
maiming and killing of people in
argentina are now like say their
subcontractees
and not only that but the u.s is trying
to make
a regional type of kind of a nato it's
called saito
which is a good saito for sado said
but anyway with south africa taking care
of the area in the indian ocean
and africa and argentina taking care of
central america and south america in
fact argentina said they would be glad
to come up and help
with the el salvadorian folks right
that's correct uh
argentina if there's a country in the
world that has
perfected the art of torture and the art
of making people disappear it is
argentina and thousands upon thousands
of argentinians
have have disappeared and
i think that this article demonstrates
and this was an article which
we did a lot of research on and which
was the result of a lot of press reports
which came out
in some of them in south africa itself
of the fact that the sea
that the argentinians had sent some of
their more renowned and
best known torturers to south africa
because they
could no longer uh
be active in argentina they were so well
known so they sent them to south africa
as part of the diplomatic corps in the
argentine embassy
they were special in torture yes
go ahead it is unclear at this point
whether they were advising the south
africans who also
know a good deal about how to torture
people and how to
uh how to make people die in prison as
they have the highest rate of death of
people in
in their prisons whether in fact they're
training each other is unclear but
certainly they have a good deal of
sharing and common interests
involved we showed the movie on company
business which you are
sections of the movie on company
business which you might remember
this movie showed the complicity of the
cia with torture all around the world as
a matter of fact there are cia torture
schools in the united states they bring
people over here from various
countries abroad police military
teach them the very sophisticated ways
of torture then they go back
and operate on their own folks back home
and just to make sure that
everything goes right the cia then has
their agents which
go down and supervise they hold clinics
they bring people off the streets and
torture them i mean it sounds like
something which
you couldn't even think up out of a sick
imagination but this is what goes on
and the next article in your bulletin
for
march talks about the salvadorian
deserter
who disclosed the green beret torture
role this was in the news just recently
and it has actually the transcript and
the considerable summary
of what actually went on it showed the
americans
supervising and helping out and they
tortured the first person to show that
uh house be done this is a 14 year old
boy and the next person brought in was a
13 year old girl of course after raping
her then they let the el salvadorians
try it
and make sure they did it right it
it's a gruesome story and i think this
is an example of
something that the american people are
being asked to overlook or to
turn the blind eye to that is the
brutality of the salvadoran government
it is not a case of salvadoran
of president duarte as quote-unquote a
moderate person who is trying to stand
up
to the forces both from left and right
which the new york times always says
exactly it was in fact the new york
times in a story in january who
disclosed
the first part of the story which was
that the green berets
eight of them were present during a
torture session and it was a major story
uh strangely it was such a major story
but it was on page two of the new york
times rather than on page one
but it was a very big and important
story i would say
however that uh
one of the reasons i guessed was that
the the salvadoran
the member of the salvadoran army who
talked about this who is now
deserted and was living in mexico
he was somewhat intimidated i guess by
talking to the new york times and he's
later revealed to the to mexican media
and that's the transcript in the store
in this article
that the special forces and i should say
the u.s special forces was created
originally by the cia
the special forces were actually
involved in the torture as opposed to
standing by observing it
they said they didn't rape the little
girl though i mean there is some
morality left
right louis how does this torture and
all of these cia covert operations
fit into american foreign policy as a
whole you have a couple articles in your
current journal
about the role of the cia and these
sorts of operations we're talking about
within american foreign policy could you
focus on that for a minute
well i i guess it comes down to the the
whole
doctrine that the united states feels it
has to
keep its role in its fear of influence
or
spheres of influence
and part of this is putting governments
in power and part of it is keeping them
in power
now there are many governments with whom
the united states
has been closely identified around the
country who cannot stay in power without
massive repression and
of course el salvador is one there are
many others around the world in
all the three continents uh argentina
and south africa for two
absolutely obviously uh south korea is
another example uh
and the philippines uh i think
uh we have to understand though that
what why would the united states do this
is it simply to keep
somebody who is a friend of the united
states in power
success of presidents and it's not just
reagan and it's not carter before him
it's successful president since
basically since the 50s since eisenhower
have
been working hand in glove and even have
been
on camera embracing successive dictators
with whom we've been identified
the most recent example if you remember
was the case of
of jimmy carter embracing the shah of
iran a few months before he was
overthrown
on the steps of the white house
i think it's because of
the cia's involvement and in fact
direction
of much of these activities it's not
that the cia is working
on its own as some people suggest as a
rogue elephant
the cia works directly under the
under the uh guidance and direction of
the
chief of state of the president and of
course this this
president not only doesn't know but
doesn't want to know
every day what the cia is doing but the
fact of the matter is that they
that they're doing what the president
asked them to do
and the other thing i should just
mention quickly is that the cia carries
out these activities to keep
the interests of the corporations u.s
corporations who have
great interests at stake for example in
south africa
and in all the other countries we've
mentioned that's right the
multinationals value
stability above everything else plus the
ability to
operate there keep the economy low as
far as wages and be able to take the
riches out of the country and these
right-wing dictatorships let them do
that course there's a point
which is reached that like in el
salvador once it gets too far and the
people really start
not a revolution then the multinationals
suffer there
and there is a certain level beyond
which the u.s
when it becomes publicly known as
opposed to known in the country itself
publicly known in the united states that
the u.s is so closely identified with
such a repressive
regime as today in el salvador
that it finally realizes it has to fish
or cut bait it has to decide whether we
continue to
support this openly or whether we have
to find other ways to support as
as for example argentina has now offered
we understand directly to the united
states to
be a surrogate for the us in in el
salvador
also honduras is playing that role this
is what's so chilling about this
agent's identities information act
that it will cover over the possibility
of the media exposing the worst abuses
of the cia which will mean the american
people won't know what it's doing we'll
have a secret
government and we will therefore
increase the power
and the scope of operations of the cia
whereas in the past when there has been
media and public focus on cia
operations and excesses there has been
pressure to cut back
on the cia i think however the most
threatening part of this is the is the
whole
move towards greater and greater secrecy
and uh so that the media
will not even have the opportunity to
report on this whole area
it will be illegal almost for a
journalist
for one of the major media to write or
to report
about intelligence in many ways that
will just be beyond the pale
now this also ties in with the progress
of senate bill one
in the senate or the great grand center
senate bill one which is designed to
take away a lot of our civil liberties
we're gradually becoming a police state
really looks like doesn't it
well well i don't
feel it's uh fair to
be rhetorical about this i agree that
there is a move
and towards greater and greater secrecy
and greater and greater
or less and less accountability of the
government to the people
and there are of course a lot of
people who are opposed to this including
quite a few members of congress for
example
29 members of congress signed a
resolution challenging the right of the
president to
intervene in el salvador under the war
powers act uh
he has no right to to do this and
they're challenging his right
and that's 29 members out of hundreds
but it is a significant
i think indication that there is even in
the halls of congress
opposition to his policies as well as in
the country at large i mean the
overwhelming majority are against
reagan's policy
in el salvador and i think the
recent polls have shown that the
foreign policy in general is not
entirely accepted or is
there is great doubt and great
wonderment
as to whether there's any continuity
whether the policy is thought out
whether it's based on
realities or only the uh very
anti-communist rhetoric of this
administration
there are also quite a few people
high in the administration who have
intelligence backgrounds and
this is another indication that the that
the uh
intelligence is on the on the rise
in this administration this is the final
question and to conclude what can the
american people
do against these worst excesses of the
cia
and indeed against the threats to all of
our civil liberties
involved in some of these bills that are
being passed that will unleash the cia
i think the biggest thing is that people
can educate themselves as to what is
going on
to read their press and to demand to
know what is going on from
from the media to
try and exercise their rights that is to
let their congress their member of
congress know that they don't
accept whatever the policy may be
even to demonstrate publicly if they're
opposed to these activities i think most
of all is to be
to keep themselves informed and to speak
out against it
well thank you very much let's focus on
one of the current
and most spectacular revelations that
the cia has made in recent years
and that is their expose of nicaragua
that was just
yesterday the day before we're taping
this where a department of fence
personnel and a cia director
bobby inman i think it was claimed
to have photographs that showed that
nicaragua was greatly increasing their
military forces that it was on the same
model
as cuba's that this was all being funded
by the soviet union
that nicaragua was systematically
carrying out
genocidal operations against indian
tribes living
in nicaragua where they had pictures of
villages that had been
destroyed what would your attitude
towards
this be i think the first time that i
can remember
since the bay of pigs that a single uh
there may have been one other case but
it's almost the only case since then
that the cia or u.s intelligence has
disclosed satellite data
from which they say this came now
satellite data by its very nature
and depending on how far they enlarge it
can be made to prove anything uh these
pictures
i'm not saying i do not know i have not
seen the pictures but
uh we are asked to believe that these
picture pictures were
taken within the last several months in
nicaragua or over nicaragua by u.s
satellites
we are further asked to believe that the
the
activity which is portrayed in these
pictures uh
is taking place as of now
recently secretary hague said
and he held it up as as the smoking gun
in a press conference
that his information was that the
nicaraguan government was engaged in
massive repression against the mosquito
indians right that was the big point
they made again yesterday with these
pictures of burned out villages
well one of those the picture to which
secretary hague referred to in his press
conference
ten days ago was a picture which was
published in the figaro
magazine in in paris and
it later turned out that that picture
had been published with a caption
saying that this was the nicaragua the
present nicaraguan government
showing them burning houses and burning
people alive i believe
it turned out that that picture and le
figaro has admitted it since then
was a picture that was taken during the
samosa rule
and that those pictures were five four
five years old
and of course mr hague has had to
or general hague has had to pull back on
that one but they are now still saying
that there is massive repression against
the mosquito indians
i would simply point out that it's a
dichotomy and a contradiction
for this government to
give a great deal of attention to the
human rights of
mosquitoes if in fact these abuses are
taking place
when in fact native americans are not
accorded the same attention by our
government
nor are the el salvadorian people who
are systematically being
killed by these death squads and the
guatemalan indians
are being almost annihilated it's almost
a genocidal campaign by the guatemalan
government against the indians in
guatemala
i do hope that some of this
well first of all there is a a lot of
evidence coming out that the
uh part of the campaign by the cia
against nicaragua isn't is through
paramilitary units and squads of
somas former soma sista soldiers who are
being trained in honduras
and their campaign is against these
mosquito indians and a lot of hundreds
of mosquitoes have been killed
by those squads and cross-border raids
one of the reasons why that
the nicaraguan government has been
forced i believe by these campaigns to
to move a lot of these people away from
the areas where they're in danger
is because of those activities not
because of a policy of the nicaraguan
government it's as a result what would
their
reason to have genocide against these
tribes the current government nicaragua
the state department hasn't given any
hypotheses about why
they would be engaging in this i can't
see any motive for it yeah it seems
strange
well they pretend and would have us
believe that the nicaraguan government
is is a totalitarian one-party
top-down dictatorial rule and that they
have no
uh wish to integrate the mosquito
indians into into their
into a society into their society and
that furthermore they
have us believe that the mosquitoes want
to secede or want to have an independent
country or state or at least an area
which they can call a separate country
i don't think there's any evidence to
show that that's what the mosquito
indians
wish john since the time we did that
interview with lewis wolf there's been
quite a few revelations about
cia covert operations in nicaragua
can you comment on those i think there
was some stories in these times
about some of the things that the cia
was up to there i can
comment in a speculative way since i i
don't you know i'm i'm
analyzing the news now based on my past
experience of course
but uh let's see what's the inflation
rate
since uh 1975 to 1982.
in america yeah what would that amount
to five years
it's been about 10 a year almost even
more
the point is that the ci's budget it's
been announced that the the ci
the president signed an order on the
first of december ordering the ci
into full paramilitary covert action
against nicaragua from honduras
organizing mercenaries to destabilize
the countryside
to counter the cuban aggression in that
country is what what they announced was
the justification
and the budget they were given was 19
million
i compare that with the 14 million that
i was given in 1975. and i'm going in
for the angolan operation the parallels
are quite striking you know there were
parallels with the angolan operation in
the bay of pigs
uh for example and other covert actions
but then guatemala was different and
iran was different so you know each one
each situation is different but here
we have so it's so close they're working
from honduras we were working from zaire
and kinshasa
they're working with ex samosas
we were working with the portuguese
exiles portuguese who had fled for
example
creating an army out of these people
also
they have quote mercenaries
but actually soldiers who were sent from
argentina for example and venezuela and
chile and colombia
to to join this force we had people
coming from various places from france
for example and of course the south
african force
they're functioning
i could i could map out the the office
for you the program
the international program some things
that i would observe if you've read my
book is that
such an operation is global the
commander would not be sitting in
honduras running the thing
the commander of the nicaraguan task
force
will be in washington he will be sending
agents
all around the world coordinating
different aspects of this thing
they'll be sending cables to every
station in the world
advising the chief of station what his
activity should be these will be the
local police and the local president the
local press
to create an atmosphere supporting to
the greatest extent possible what
they're doing
seeking arms that aren't attributable
seeking sources of
news comments and releases that can be
put together in white papers to to
persuade
and then the bottom line that the
justification reagan has given and the
ci have given
for doing this intervention
is to counter the cuban activities in
nicaragua but see the point
is that they're not going to be any
cubans die in this thing
they're i believe there it said that
there are 2 000 cubans in nicaragua now
they're functioning to help build an
airport and no doubt military
advising although i've i've not seen
that confirmed anywhere
a lot of doctors medical personnel
doctors and medical personnel and
teachers and whatnot
and from italy and several other
countries as well it's not just cubans
oh indeed nicaragua but a variety of
countries the nicaraguan arms it's been
shown are not coming from the soviet
union they're buying them from france
and italy
and all kinds of other places or are
they coming from from
from cuba this has been proven but but
the point is that this program of the ci
is not going to be killing
cubans it's going to be killing
nicaraguans
it's not going to be killing nicaraguan
officials not that many nicaraguan
soldiers it's going to be destabilizing
the countryside blowing up bridges
ambushing bush buses if they follow the
pattern that they have in other places
there will be some schools
bombed and marketplaces bombed to
destabilize the economy so it can't
function so the network and fabric of
society will break down
they kill village leaders i've read that
the phoenix program being duplicated
killing village leaders hauling people
out and executing them to terrify
terrorize them from
from cooperating with the government and
their families and their families
in fact the last three weeks in these
times has had some very good articles on
nicaragua
that indicates that from honduras some
hit squads were sent into nicaragua that
have killed at least 30 leaders and
just innocent people in that region and
have
terrorized peasants and people living in
nicaragua near the honduras border
because of these hit raids although on
the other hand they've led these people
to organize and become even
more firm and resolute in their will to
protect
their country so sometimes these
destabilization programs backfire
and end up stabilizing the country and
unifying it certainly did in the bay of
pigs the ci invasion there
a unified cuba under a fidel castro
he came out of that thing 10 times 100
times stronger than he was going into it
and and that probably will be in effect
in nicaragua
these nicaraguans dying will be added to
the 800
000 i mentioned earlier the the victims
people who die as a direct
as direct victims of ci covert actions
in the last 30 years the minimum figure
given by all responsible parties in
press and government studies and whatnot
is eight hundred thousand the figures
range from eight hundred thousand to a
couple of million victims of ci
operations indirect type of indirect
now that does not include for example
the people who died in the vietnam war
which was
a direct result of a cia covert action
more than what million and a half in
indonesia the million and a half in
indonesia now that's that's a lot of
dead people now the circumstances of
this killing
are pure terrorism recruiting terrorists
to go across the
border and blow up and assassinate and
kill
we have to remember that the next time
president reagan or alexander
the hague are making their pious
statements about the threat of
international terrorism and the horrors
of international terrorism
the united states is without any serious
competition
leading the world in international
terrorism today
and for the past 30 years john isn't
there something unique about this
nicaraguan situation is that
the administration is openly admitting
that they are
carrying it on that's truly a difference
and
this gets back to the rogue elephant is
the ci
a rogue elephant or is it has it all
these years been doing what the
president
wants and of course the truth is both in
some cases it's done what it wanted
contrary to presidential orders in other
cases it's done
what the president probably wanted but
didn't
say in this case because of the nature
of the secretary of state and the
president
the the cia is clearly doing exactly
what the president wanted now
the president didn't hold a press
conference to say
i'm sending in the cia to kill people in
nicaragua
but it has been admitted by the white
house that they did
it's been leaked and the president
smiled at the leaks that
he did order the ci into this action so
he's
clearly you know he's he sees himself as
a
you know marshall reagan uh uh
sort of you know showing off how he can
shoot you know let those people know
he's got
got something he can do louis while
we're on central america
we might also note that your group has
published a book
called white paper white wash in which
you analyze the infamous
white paper that was published by the
american government to justify
american intervention in el salvador can
you
just briefly indicate some of the
obvious whitewash
in the white paper and some of the
things published in your book and then
maybe we can tell our audience where
they can get this
the white paper was published uh in 1979
by
by uh well i should say i'm sorry there
were prior
indications of of propaganda about
u.s intervention in el salvador but the
the original white paper
that we're talking about here came out
in 1981 february february 1981
and it was uh said to have been captured
the series of documents that were
captured
by the salvadoran armed forces
now we should remember first of all that
there were three
accounts offered as to how the
information was captured one said it was
found by state department intelligence
men who went to
to el salvador and saw it on a table in
the headquarters of the salvadoran armed
forces
a second account said that it was found
in what was called a safe house of the
guerrillas
in san salvador and the third and most
unlikely account was that it was
captured from a gorilla who was found
walking through the streets of el
salvador with a whole packet of
documents under his arm each of those
accounts were offered as
the source of of these documents
uh we have analyzed uh the documents
that's in in this book uh
co-co-edited by uh warner pulsar edited
by warner protel with interviews
with philip agee and
it's very interesting to analyze as has
been done in the book
line by line word by word the the
so-called white paper
there are parts of the paper for example
that refer to
in english sections of the so-called
spanish original spanish language
documents that don't exist
uh there are creative translation
exactly there are
there's one document for example that's
partly in spanish
in handwritten spanish and then on the
same document it's typewritten in
english
so we're asked to believe that whomever
was sitting down at the table writing
these
shopping lists for arms from cuba from
vietnam from
ethiopia where and libya
was going to move from pen in in spanish
to a typewriter and type in english
and very i might say very literal very
literary english
there are a lot of contradictions in the
white paper basically we should
understand this because it was
and is the the first and and the most
important justification that has been
used by the government
for its intervention in el salvador of
course now they
pretend that because the white paper was
so widely discredited
even by one of its authors who who gave
an interview to the wall street journal
and disclosed that he even had a lot of
questions about it
um so i think there's a lot of reason
that this document or this
exercise in propaganda is a classic in
cia propaganda
if the audience wants to order this book
how can they get it
well they can write to the publisher
which is deep cover publications
should i give the address in post office
box
677 new york new york 10013 and it's uh
uh well 650 plus a dollar fifty handling
yeah
and can people also get the mailing list
for your other publications
you've published a book called dirty
work the cia in western europe
and another one called dirty work the
cia in africa
as well as putting out this covert
action information
bulletin will you give information and
how they can order
that uh those other they can write to us
to covert action information bullets in
in washington i'll give the address
post office box 50272-50272 washington
dc 2 0004
and we'll be happy to send you the
information
i find this very sad by the way
i find it troubles me
not obviously because i was once part of
all this but also
just as an american citizen to realize
that this country
is indulging in activities that are just
as cruel and just as as depraved
in some cases and almost as extensive as
what for example the
the gestapo indulged in in germany
we haven't liquidated five million
jews but eight hundred thousand minimum
figure people
killed in terrorist circumstances in the
third world
is a lot of people dead and the
responsibility
ultimately yes you know it's done by the
cia and it's a secret organization
and therefore we have plausible denial
to our own consciences
because there's nothing we can do about
it we don't know about it they didn't
consult us
but the other side of that coin is that
the ci
is the united states police organ
and what it does we the american people
are responsible
for so that in addition to the personal
losses
of freedom of speech and freedom of the
press we
are responsible for the genocide of
terrorism that's taking place against
the world today
in our name and with our tax dollars and
with the changes of the laws
and executive orders the whole
apparatus of the intelligence services
including the fbi
and their right-wing hit squad buddies
like the nazis and the klan
are now being able to be turned on the
american people turned on the americans
with impunity
remember that lou wolf mentioning the
executive order
which we've all followed with great
interest that too
is president reagan going public
bragging about what he's doing with the
cia but don't forget
that the ci has always functioned
extensively
inside the united states mh chaos you
know a billion dollar program was all
domestic
and experim mk ultra experimentation on
on american citizens
with drugs and lsd and whatnot that went
on for 20 years and that was
inside the united states on american
guinea pigs the opening of mail for 20
years
was american citizens mail they've
always done this thing the operation
mongoose war against cuba was run from
from florida and they had over a
thousand safe houses
and boat docks and whatnot that they
were operating from the united states
the training facilities
for torture for interrogation techniques
were in
san antonio texas at one time a few
years back and you know that's something
that's easy to move somewhere else i
don't know where it is today
john recently one of the individuals in
the cia that was in charge of these
covert
operations has recently resigned and
that is admiral bobby inman who was
allegedly
second in command at the cia it's been
widely reported that
inman himself believed that william
casey who is the director of the cia
was overly fond of quote adventurous but
ill-advised cia operations aboard
abroad and senator joseph biden of
delaware has recently noted
without inman the intelligence agencies
may be given license to try
all kinds of questionable things here
and abroad
in the light of what they've been doing
even under inman already
what would be your comments on the inman
resignation in the future
of the cia well i would have to regret
the fact that he left
not that he was a paragon of liberal
virtue
but he seemed to be when compared with
william casey and and some of the others
jesse helms over on the senate side
carlucci his predecessor he seemed to
have some pretty strong instincts for
protecting american institutions
he protested the names of agents bill at
one time or at least one version of it
as being unessential to american
national security and of course he got a
lot of criticism for that
it would seem that he was in in effect a
moderating influence
on some of the cruel or instincts of
men like casey who of course is a
very inept and corrupt individual
the corruption being that he's
maintained his own business portfolio
he's a millionaire
while he's ci director he's running the
cia he's running his own businesses and
of course from the cia
he can have some influence on world
economic matters
he has also been appearing at republican
fundraisers and of course that's one of
the biggest no
no's in in
the united states governmental system to
have the head
of a police organization with the
influence of the cia
to openly advocate one political party's
position and help it raise money
in that kind of of a corrupt
adventuresome
atmosphere one would have to regret
inman's resignation
the whole milieu the environment is
favorable to reagan and the ci and what
they want to accomplish what they are
accomplishing
if you go one step further
and consider reagan's policies his first
year in office
he's muted this a little bit faced with
a clear
indication by the american
people populous about war
he and and attila the hague
were speaking constantly
about the viability of nuclear war
war was an effective tool we shouldn't
be afraid of war
going to war in el salvador discussing
sending troops into nicaragua
talking frequently about going to the
source quote in cuba
and uh talking about you know
demonstration wars or limited wars
nuclear wars in europe and what not
these people gave every indication that
they were looking for
war now they have
toned this down a little bit in the last
two months
first you saw the turn we all saw the
turn everybody reads the newspapers
when the polls responded 89
of the american people said they were
did not favor american
military intervention in nicaragua
and uh this was a pretty clear
indication to the
the president that the american people
were not going to support him he would
not be a successful president
if he got us into a war it would be
something that he would have trouble
selling trouble maintaining at the same
time there was a move in congress that
if the government of el salvador didn't
modify its human rights positions they
wouldn't get more money for aid
and then the second thing of course has
been this massive groundswell reaction
to his attitudes towards the bomb
and that's national every corner of the
nation
little bitty towns across the nation
organizing effectively and having big
demonstrations
as well as the big the big cities
the nation and the world so deeply
concerned
about the threat of nuclear war and just
absolutely horrified that you could
possibly have a president in office
whose mental capacities were so limited
that he would
actually talk publicly of demonstration
atom bombs in europe
popping off a bomb to show our will and
resolve
limiting nuclear war to europe and the
possibility of
surviving nuclear war in the united
states this has horrified people to the
point where he's got a big
political problem on his hand from the
famous ground zero and the freeze
and the result is that it's it's forcing
a change in their stated policies and
attitudes they're toning down
quite a bit from what they were saying a
year ago at this time for example
responding to the mood of the nation and
some
frustration i think clearly well thank
you john that's fine
we've exhausted you again but we
appreciate